at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by fresh books fresh
books has become the go-to cloud
accounting software for literally
millions of small business owners who
found a faster more efficient and much
less stressful way to deal with their
numbers and ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at it is used
by many of the fastest growing startups
I've invested in or advise and it's
equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 seconds you can
set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about 2
clicks which on average will get you
paid twice as fast their new proposals
feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline as part of your
estimate there are many many other
things
tracking your time the quick proposals
that I mentioned formatting free
super-easy late payment reminders so you
don't have to chase people automatic
expenses sharing files and messages with
your clients award-winning customer
service they are extremely responsive
the interface is super intuitive and
there's almost no learning curve so in
short it's easy it saves you time and
right now fresh books is offering an
unrestricted 30-day free trial for all
of my listeners to claim yours check it
out go to FreshBooks dot-com forward
slash tim and enter tim ferriss in the
how did you hear about a section and
that is funky spell t IM f e RR is s so
again go to fresh books comm forward
slash tim and enter tim ferriss and how
did you hear about us section check it
out
this episode is brought to you by
audible audible provides an unbeatable
selection of audio books including
bestsellers how-to mysteries thrillers
memoirs and more I've used audible for
many years and I have a few audio books
to recommend right off the bat number
one ready player one by Ernest Cline so
listen to the book that caught the
attention of Spielberg enough to get
made into a major film the writing is
fantastic the Tao Seneca by Seneca the
younger this is a collection of letters
my favorite compilation of letters of
all time that I've recommended the most
of all the books I've ever read and the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman this is
the fiction book that I used to convert
nonfiction purists into fiction lovers
I like the version that Neil reads
himself but that's just me he is a
hypnotic voice I also recently enjoyed
nonviolent communication by Marshall
Rosenberg which was recommended to me by
best-selling author and Neil Strauss
make sure to get the audiobook version
and you will recognize it by the peace
sign on the cover and as an audible
subscriber you can choose three titles
every month one audiobook and two
audible originals you can't hear
anywhere else and there's some really
really cool stuff among the audible
originals you can listen on any device
anytime anywhere at home at the gym
while you're cooking on your commute or
wherever I often listen to audiobooks
when I'm walking my pooch or on the way
to the gym so on and so forth you'll
also enjoy easy audio book exchanges in
other words if you don't like what you
buy and you're like I've buyer's remorse
you can swap it rollover credits so if
you don't use credits in a given month
they were all over into the next and an
audiobook library you keep forever even
if you cancel this last part is
important unlike say a streaming or
rental service with audible you own your
books even if you cancel your membership
and right now for a limited time you can
get three months of audible for just 695
a month that's 6.95 a month and that is
also more than half off the regular
price so give yourself the gift of
listening and while you're at it think
about giving the gift of audible to
someone on your list for more go to
audible.com forward slash Tim T I am
that is audible com forward slash Tim or
text Tim T im2 505
hundred why hello boys and girls this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job each and every episode this
one included to interview and dissect
world-class performers of all different
types business sports chess
entertainment music sometimes folks who
span many multiple disciplines and this
is one of those cases in my mind at
least we have Dave Ellis sitting across
from me Dave how are you I'm great man
I'm happy to be here on Instagram and
Twitter and elsewhere at Dave ela ela TZ
h Dave Eiland OTT calm Instagram would
be probably first choice for checking
him out and I'll read the bio and then I
have all sorts of questions about the
bio but I think before I get into that
it's helpful to perhaps his contact for
some folks mention what I said to my
girlfriend last night who's who asked me
fairly who is Dave why is he in the
house I'm not in an accusatory way more
out curiosities and you were helping to
set up my first ever drum kit you know
after many many misfires which we won't
get into right now there are a lot of
people very very high on drugs will
volunteer to help you assemble kits
turns out they don't follow the
directions very well and I wanted her to
hear you play just a tool around after
we had consumed many pounds of pork and
biscuits and sorts of other Texan health
good yes and she had asked me at some
point the day before mostly as a
hypothetical question but also she was
very curious I wonder who Annie goes to
for relationship advice and Annie in
this case is a very well known
relationship coach / therapist and who
does the relationship coach Rowe too for
relationship advice and I use that as a
bridge to say well many of the musicians
you think of many of the best drummers
you might see on stage go to Dave as
sort of the drumming whisperer / like
mechanic fixer yes among many other
things so let's jump into the bye
but for those people who were listening
in her who are thinking to themselves
well I really don't know anything about
drumming I really don't know either my
music this is an audio only format I'm
not going to watch Dave smashing on his
kit we are going to jump across all
sorts of different topics Sophie or not
maybe but let's let's get into the the
basic bio so Davey Ilitch first garnered
attention with his band daughters of
Mara's debut album I am destroyer in
2007 very appropriate debut album named
for a lot of reasons but his time
touring with the American progressive
rock band The Mars Volta in 2009-2010 is
what really put him on the map and
certainly put you on my map which we can
get to he has since worked with Miley
Cyrus Justin Timberlake m83 the 1975
Juliette Lewis big black Delta and many
many others he conducts master class
lectures worldwide and in fact you are
going to be conducting a master class
tomorrow yep here in Austin Texas which
is exciting and is a regular in the LA
session scene and I want to come back to
a bunch of vocab here that we can
dissect including performing on film
scores for many major motion pictures
and I have questions about that as an
educator for the last 20 years which for
people who have listened his podcast for
a while he is part of what makes you so
interesting to me is not just the
ability to perform but the ability to
transmit and to break down and to convey
and to demystify mm-hmm let's back to
the sentence as an educator for last 20
years David's developed reputation as
the technique body mechanic specialist
who has helped many of the world's top
players and educators overcome physical
and mental plateaus at his private
studio in Los Angeles and your brand-new
online course
getting out of your own way which is
perhaps the best title of any course
I've ever encountered it is available at
Davie let's calm I've checked it out it
is [ __ ] awesome thank you and I have
spent a lot of time thinking about
teaching I've spent a lot of time
thinking about learning and I'm by no
means a musician but have also digested
a fair amount of material related to
drumming and I cannot recommend it
thanks highly enough I thought we could
start with
your t-shirt that you're wearing right
now and it's a t-shirt that I liked so
much at one point when we hung out in LA
and smashed on some drums and then ate a
bunch of Himalayan yak if I remember
correctly yeah I asked you where I could
get one of these shirts yeah so could
you describe for people what you're
wearing at the moment and why yeah
absolutely
so I'm wearing one of my t-shirts that I
you know makin are available on my
website that that say slow down on the
front and do it again on the back and it
came from me having to say that over and
over and over again to people as I was
teaching them so it's got tired of
yelling at people saying the same [ __ ]
over and over again so I just pointed my
shirt now and I just go come on let's
slow it down because so many people it's
not about what you're trying to learn as
much as it is about how you approach
learning it which is obviously a
universal concept and so many people try
to just rush through things so quickly
and especially when you're doing
something that's so physically and
mentally demanding as drumming if you
don't approach it slowly your brain has
no idea what your body's doing so all
these people try and rush through
something and they physiologically have
no idea what's going on and also do it
again because the sheer amount of
repetition you have to do to really plug
in that muscle memory
and and it's fun I made it just kind of
as a joke kind of you know and then
people would come up to me on the street
be like oh I love that shirt because
people get whatever sort of meaning they
want a Rorschach blot test yeah yeah
absolutely
people and people love it and they get
whatever they want out of it and it can
mean all sorts of different things you
know and this I think also highlights
for me a difference between a really
critical difference in learning anything
or several critical differences one is
developing a skill versus demonstrating
mmm
and you could you could apply that to
say strength development versus display
mm-hmm competing and say powerlifting
versus training for powerlifting and in
this case I think it may be a good
contrast that comes to mind would be
last night sitting down at this
electronic drum kit mmm my first kit of
of that type that I've ever used and
playing with the basic posture and body
mechanics and see you would ask me to
relinquish control of my arm and provide
dead weight and to do the same with my
leg to try to ensure that for instance
when using the and I never know if I
should call it a kick or a bass or
something something else
keep your bass drum or pedal rather that
I'd be using my hip as opposed to
getting wickety-wack with my ankle yes
or other articulation and in aiming to
do that ensuring that I'm not leaning
back like I'm in an Easy Rider because
that creates all sorts of instability
and it was incredible to me but not
surprising given my time with you that
within about a hundred and twenty
seconds you took one of my greatest
sources of discomfort sitting at any kit
which was feeling like I had to be kind
of balanced on my left ass cheek to make
the bass pedal work really yeah and you
remove that so now I could have a little
bit of anterior pelvic tilt and four
people are wondering what that means
imagine your hips are a glass of wine
if you pour wine out the front that's
anterior pelvic tilt posterior pelvic
tilt be pouring wine out the back and so
having a little bit of tilt forward so
that I can feel my sits bones mm-hmm on
the stool which you also help me to do
by taking a weight plate is in the
garage and the gym is also there and
putting on top of it so you diagnosed
that very quickly and then we practice a
very slow basic sort of ACDC
yeah Rach come on money be the money
yeah yeah and in doing that we were able
to focus on some really fundamental
grips and so on in a very slow fashion
but the video that introduced you to me
has some a number it turns out of
stories associated with it that I hadn't
heard
seems like a lot of people have come to
find you through this video so I'd love
to tell people about it and I think it
came about because I was on Twitter that
God knows what my holy hour and was
thinking about drumming and I've always
been fascinated by drumming so I asked
something along the lines of like who is
a beast drummer who was also a good
teacher and somebody threw a link up to
this video mm-hmm what is the video so
the video is me playing with the Mars
Volta
of Big Day Out festival in Sydney
Australia in 2010 early 2010 and I would
videotape all of the shows that we
played I'd set up a little camera behind
me because when you're in the heat of
battle you know as you could say you
have no idea how it's actually coming
across so if I backtrack a little bit
with this situation and a lot of
situations that I could call for I've
sort of developed this reputation as a
bit of a mercenary in that like when
someone breaks their arm or someone gets
fired or someone needs someone to do it
tour like the last minute no rehearsals
little rehearsal whatever they call me
and I have to learn everything
last-minute and it's it's funny I'm the
cleaner yeah and so you know with with
with the mars volta with miley cyrus
with 1975 with m83 you walk into a room
you go nice to meet you guys and you
might run through the set once and then
you're playing in front of fifteen
twenty thirty thousand people and it's a
very unique situation to be and the
amount of pressure is unbelievable
because as a drummer if you drop the
ball the whole show collapses in on top
of you it's not like you know guitar
where you can just like whoops flub that
and then you can just kind of keep
playing do it twice and play jazz
exactly yeah with drumming if you drop
the ball like the whole show caves in on
you so
so the Mars Volta was you know the first
big situation that I was in like that I
got that gig when I was 25 they called
hundreds of people to do it people are
sending in video auditions and all kinds
of stuff
and one day asked me to do it I I said
yeah sure you know in your hits one of
them sure you've had this experience
before they're like great this sounds
great do you want to do it in my head
I'm like no no no no no and then I was
just like yes yes just comes out of your
mouth and I feel like every important
life decision I've ever made that
happens and it's super important to just
do it no matter how can grow wings on
the way down yes exactly
and so so I so I flew to Europe met the
band we ran through the two and a half
hour set twice and then we're on tour
and this is like for people who aren't
familiar with the band it's extremely
complex music lots of like Omar the
guitar player lots of hand signals and
eyebrows and and and cues and you have
didn't realize it yeah yes so he's like
a major league baseball catch yes yeah
and and you know there's a long drum
solo every night yeah so there's you
have to really be on point so I would
set up a camera behind me every night to
just be like I need to know what this
actually sounds like because in in the
heat of the moment you could think
you're killing it and then you watch a
video and you're like whoops or the
opposites also true always I could be
like I really really do you know that
doesn't that didn't sound good at all
and then I watched the video I'm like oh
that was actually okay so that level of
cognitive disconnect is in that scenario
is huge so I would go back to my hotel
room after the show and watch the video
and you know take mental notes about
things that worked and things that
didn't work and for me it's always been
very important to put on a visual show I
there's nothing worse than going to see
a show and just watching someone looks
like they're doing their taxes
why do you think this particular video
and we'll put it in the show notes so
for people who want to see it you just
go to my blog forward slash podcast and
they'll be right in the show notes you
can find the link but if people wanted
to Google this is there anything in
particular they should search for you
just type in davie let's drum cam or
just de viewlets and it's gonna pop up
at the top there it's one of the very
first yes why do you think this video
and is related to where you're going I
think why do you think this video caught
on and the way that it did because I'm
going apeshit standing up kicking stuff
over you know like just going nuts yeah
like I think it's really important to
put on a show so people are like holy
[ __ ] hey what is go this is insane yeah
you know and so yeah I'm standing up and
hitting super hard and it's it's
visually entertaining but the most
important part of that is the playing
has to be happening if you you know go
nuts and then you screw something up
there's a point you know so the playing
has to be on point and then I'm gonna
stand up and kick something over and you
know before you had your first whether
it's your first performance with the
Mars Volta hmm so you've gone through
the set twice yeah you're in Europe yeah
wherever you are
yeah in the world yeah what is what is
your self-talk or your prep before going
out on stage to play yeah
with this band yeah so you'll be into
this because there's a lot of
note-taking yeah I'm already into it so
this is something that I do with a lot
of people that I work with just showing
them how to properly chart out a song
because so many people write out way too
much nonsense and then it's way too much
to navigate and learning music at the
last minute having to play it is you
know that does happen you know quite a
bit rather it's like a coffeehouse or a
huge show or whatever so most people
will write out everything and then they
go to look at it and they have no idea
what they can't read their handwriting
and so
like what I do with people is it's just
the roadmap you're not writing out
notation you're not writing out it's
just like intro eight bars first 16 bars
chorus 60 it's just that that's it
like and I might say where my right hand
is ride cymbal crash hi-hat but it's
very minimalistic and so I made those
charts for all the songs and I would I
would go through it's all about how you
approach this stuff right so a lot of
people would go I'm gonna play through
the setlist just bang bang bang down
down the line but you're constantly
distracted you're constantly switching
the targets moving so you can't get deep
so what I would why is the target moving
because you're switching songs all the
time so what I would do is I would take
the first song in the setlist and I
would have my notes and the music and I
would play through it as many times as
it took for me to be like I know this
really well but the same thing on repeat
most people would just go I'm just going
to go through the set and then it's now
do the do the by the sauce changing you
mean that show to show or no no I mean
like it within the setlist itself so
someone would play like the first song
and then they then the second song and
the third song all in a row right and
then they can't remember anything
because they're working on all the songs
at the same time it's linear yes yes
it's also just because we've both had a
fair amount of caffeine so I feel like
we can just make use of that caffeine
now this is also reason why certain
mnemonic devices work better than others
for instance if you use what is
sometimes referred to as a memory palace
hmm in which this has been used for
thousands of years cicero used it for
memorizing speeches among other things
where you could take this is also how a
lot of memory competitors memorize
shuffled decks of cards is they will
memorize say pairs of cards as
interacting images and place them along
a familiar route right so walking from
the their front door to the grocery
store or something like that but one of
the challenges with that is if you want
to get to the twelfth item
and recall that 12 item you have to run
through the list and similarly yes if
you're only memorizing or getting
familiar with a playlist or a set you up
from 1 to 12 or whatever the number is
yeah and then all of a sudden I'm just
imagining like lead singers like [ __ ] it
yup I'm feeling we should just go to 5
and you're like I'm not ready for photo
totally that's a very real thing and
that's a real thing also when people are
doing method book work like out of a
drum book let's say like I might have
them learn the entire page this happens
all the time and I'm like cool let me
hear you start from the end yeah and
they're like so that that that actually
is a very important point and that comes
later in the process at the end of the
process so I will just go through one
song over and over and over and over and
over again until I know it really well
and this is a this is huge practicing
not in regards to time but in regards to
goals so the amount of people who go to
music school and they go yeah I practice
eight hours a day like well you know
it's not about how much time it's about
what you're getting done and having
specific goals and and and writing that
down and go I need to get this from here
to here once I get that done I'm done
check moving on a lot of people go I
need to work on this thing for an hour
that doesn't mean anything it's not a
tangible goal an hour for you and an
hour for me are completely different
what one person could get it in 20
minutes another person takes two hours
so and it's unbelievable how everyone
structures things in terms of time how
do you know when you when you have a
song it's a good question
I don't know if I can put that into
words what does it feel like it feels
like you've given a lot of talks right
you rehearse it enough and you're like
yeah I don't need these notes I know you
know it in your core yeah it's it's like
when you memorize your times tables or
order it's that same type of thing
you're not you don't have to like gear
up to get it going someone could like
slap you in the face to wake you up and
be like do this yeah a new
just come out mm-hmm it's in your bones
yeah and I prepare in that regard like
an insane amounts like a ridiculous
amount so I'll play the song I don't
know like five or ten times with my
notes and then I'm startling like okay I
think I think I got it now then I'll put
my notes away and just play no sorry
then I'll play with just the notes no
music and then I'll play as you say so
you're playing you're accompanying the
music first with your yes and then when
I get comfortable the next step turn off
the music and just play with the notes
and then the next step is music no notes
and then the final step is just a click
track nothing else so just a metric
track metronome yeah so I'm hearing
nothing and I have to know it so well
that I can get through the whole song in
my head hearing everything and it's
that's an insane amount of work but the
deal is is when you get on stage and
there's thirty thousand people screaming
and like with Miley like people throwing
bras and underwear athletes like better
than batteries and tomatoes or beer
bottles yeah like at that moment you
have to know everything so well that
that's not gonna faze you so it takes a
long time and I'm in there for ten or
twelve hours at the beginning yeah but
but that type of preparation is is huge
and what's funny is when I went to
Amsterdam to rehearse the set with them
I set up an extra floor tom
on my left side which normally wouldn't
do that there on your right side and
we're gonna say something no no I was
just going to that was I was going to
say for maybe you could just explain
what a floor Thomas yeah yeah so so
Tom's yeah interesting it's explaining
this lay yeah so so man how would you do
it I I'm gonna do a poor job yeah great
I'll take it I will do a terrible job
ah it's easy for me to come to this with
beginners I don't know the [ __ ] back
so if people hear the kind of like snap
of a like like the generally please feel
free to call [ __ ] on anything like
that you're going to be hearing say a
snare drum right and when when you look
at drummers and they have their hands
seemingly crossed they're hitting the
hi-hat mm-hmm and then they're hitting
the snare with the other hand and that's
part of the lifeblood of any kind of
yeah rock beat right kick and the kick
drum wonderful yeah yeah exactly
that is the hi-hat and the snare yeah
and then if you if you were to hear a
drummer say travel left to right
assuming they're right-handed
mm-hmm like digga digga digga digga
digga digga that part is very often
gonna be a floor tom perfect you are
right-handed yes so you have a rack tom
up top straight in front of you which is
gonna be the higher Pat's like
doo-doo-doo and then you go down further
and though you get bigger drums which
are sitting on the floor your toms right
so having those on the left right not
not normal not normal so why would why
did you do that so I put it on my left
so I could put my notes on the left and
put no one I thought didn't think anyone
would see him and I go to the bathroom
after after the first set and I come
back it's all gone oh [ __ ] yeah and I
was like uh and the base pairs like it's
cool man you got it it's all good you
don't need those and I didn't like
thanks but bass player has done this
okay great so I want to you just uh note
something for folks and I'm so glad we
got into this because that particular
way that you laid out your progression
for practicing a song mm-hmm is nearly
identical to how a lot of the best
public speakers also prepare their
keynotes
hmm and they will say take a keynote and
I learned to do this as well but I was
borrowing from other people and instead
of doing let's just say it's a for the
sake of simplicity a 60 min
keynote rather than trying to give the
60-minute keynote from start to finish
they'll break it into say four pieces
yeah or what they'll do and this is
something I start to model is because
the beginning and the ending is so
important hmm actually breaking out like
the first five minutes and the last five
minutes so you have say five minutes
let's just make it simple if it's uh say
a forty minute talk it's to make the
math a little easier like first five
minutes then you have three ten minute
sections in the last five minutes and
then practice each one of those
individually as opposed to yes in
sequence yes and initially not paying
attention to time although having some
rough idea of the total length and then
recording listening to it making these
post-game analysis edits necessary and
then also at a later point I remember
when I was and I picked this up from
someone as well
I was practicing you're talking about
the bras when I was preparing for my my
TED talk about a year and a half ago
who's gonna be opening session mainstage
nervous as fun and just as a side note
I'm free of a million of these so I'd
love to hear some of these war stories
sir there's this area behind the stage
at Ted which is it's called something
hilarious like the Zen room or the
chill-out room where the people who are
on deck like the three or four speakers
are on deck meant to hang out there and
there are little misters and like cold
water and so on and you walk in there
and at least when I walked in there it
was some of the most polished speakers
in the world basically freaking the [ __ ]
out I need to leave here now I need to
leave right now this is like you know
being in the water with Bear Grylls and
all just survival experts in there
losing their [ __ ] because there are like
great white sharks in the water like I
can't this is not helpful I need to not
be here and but one of the things that I
had done in the last week or so of
preparation was to load myself up on way
too much caffeine like like three or
four coffees before giving dress
rehearsals to
strangers that my friends companies I
would have them call in people during
lunch hour and I would give a rehearsal
in front of people who really probably
didn't particularly want to be there
sure not a super warm crowd sir who
don't care about my feelings
particularly and you're all jacked and
I'm jacked to try to simulate the
adrenaline oh it feel that's March they
got out there yeah is he naked I don't
know that I don't don't--i brain vomit
on you team yes or reserve some of my
brain balm for later but the the point
being that that progression you use
applies to so many things well you know
we're gonna we're gonna come back you
can see me fondling these these filings
and the strange word but these gifts
that gifts people get your mind out of
the gutter that you gave me which I do
want to talk about sure see you've
you've followed this progression hmm
song by song gone through the set twice
no hour before you get on stage hmm what
does that hour look like for that for
that particular like yes very yeah it's
it's extremely stressful you're waking
up in the middle of the night going huh
how does that bridge go like huh you
know like freaking out because you have
the weight of the world on your
shoulders and it's extremely stressful
and a lot of these situations it's funny
I was thinking about how to sort of
present this to the laymen and it's like
your first day on the job it's some
really you got like a giant promotion or
like you're at a new company different
different title different role and you
roll in and you meet everyone you pick
five random people out of the office and
you say great you guys are gonna go on
stage in front of 30,000 people together
you you just met or you're gonna spend
the next month and a bus together waking
up next to each other it's a very weird
situation and who knows how that's going
to work out as far as personalities and
everything so
yeah but the the hour before the show
I'm I've done like the the Sam Harris
guided meditation I've just been just go
to an area by myself and sit down and
breathe and just try and stay as relaxed
as possible this is the the 10-minute
yeah so for people who don't know so sam
harris neuroscience PhD also very
well-known author he's just sam harris
org two hours one s has a number of
really good guided meditations you you
will have done that yeah is that the
morning of is that right before both if
i'm feeling really anxious i'll do it
right before one of the things that took
me years of touring to figure out is a
lot of people will well you know
drumming is an incredibly physical
instrument especially with how hard i
can hit at times and you have to really
treat yourself like an athlete and a lot
of people will just sit there and in
prayer and warm quote-unquote warm up
like on a rubber pad and kind of
gingerly hit it around for ten or
fifteen minutes and then they go on on
stage and there their feet are cold so i
started bringing a jump rope on tour
with me and i was just like oh my god
how did i not figure this out earlier
and so i skip rope for maybe ten or
fifteen minutes
and that gets the blood flowing so i
went to walk out on stage i feel like
i'm three songs and already which is a
game changer physiologically and so i'll
do that kind of gets your head in the
zone because because skipping rope is
the same it's the same exact thing
that's playing a musical in this
instrument in terms of focus it's like a
detached focus if you think about what
you're doing you use a different part of
your brain and neurologically and you'll
screw up whatever you're doing it if
it's a highly learned imbedded task
right so if you're skipping rope and you
think about what you're doing you'll hit
your feet and screw it all up if i'm
playing a show i have to either deed
totally zenned out not thinking about
anything at all
or i have to be like thinking about what
i'm eating after after the show her like
doing laundry or whatever
I can't think I'll here comes this part
or like right right left left
just all immediately bungle whatever I'm
doing so but skipping rope
it gets my head in that in that mindset
and and it also gets me warmed up so
yeah it's just a lot of pacing well I
don't drink coffee or Red Bulls or
anything because I know my heart rates
already gonna be insane so I try to
actually not do that and yeah do you
have anything that you any particular
rituals or things that you say to
yourself before you go out or if you are
alternatively you take either or both of
these when you're talking to a
professional who perhaps is really
nervous about a tour they're about to do
or gigs that they're doing what's your
advice to them right before they go out
my advice is what I try to live by and
if you put the time in and you know the
material there's nothing to be nervous
about because you know what you're doing
and as soon as you get on stage after
about five minutes and the adrenaline
wears off you should be comfortable
because you're like I've put in so I
couldn't have put more time in like I
put the time in I know what I'm doing
this is fine what's really scary is when
you don't have the time to put the work
in then that's freaky
which I try to never put myself in those
situations but yeah as long as you put
the time in and when I'm working with
someone and make sure they put that they
put the time in and usually it's a lot
of guys who have been in bands for a
long time they have like an ample amount
of time out of a month of rehearsals so
it's not really about do I know this
material it's maybe some other issue but
I tell everyone to do the Sam Harris
guided meditation especially people who
don't aren't familiar with that because
I when I first started doing it I
literally had to relearn how to breathe
the guided meditation yeah my breathing
was because I was I was driving to the
studio and I was recording this record
with this band auntie mask I did with
Omar and Cedric from the mars volta
after the mars volta
and flea was playing base on it from the
Chili Peppers and I had just finished
doing the killer be killed record which
was a metal band I was in and then and I
had to learn the mily set after being in
the studio all day with auntie masks so
I was driving to the studio and I was
white knuckling the steering wheel and I
was holding my breath and I realized oh
my god why am I doing this all the time
is this my novel yeah this is crazy and
then I started paying attention to it
and I realized I was holding my breath
all the time and when I started doing
that short guided meditation I realized
oh my god I don't know how to breathe
anymore
mmm so I had to literally learn how to
take a full breath because I didn't you
know from just getting kicked in the
balls over and over again and the daily
life your breathing gets get shallow
yeah so I so that was massive
for me so as far as like the the rituals
that's that's huge even if I don't have
time to like sit down and fully do the
meditation I'll I'll try and get into
that headspace because if you start your
day with that you can very easily go
back and access that mindset later on
it's much easier for me to go okay
feeling the stress like okay there's the
full breath whereas like if I didn't
start off my day doing that I might not
physically be able to access that full
breath and you haven't limbered up yes
psychologically and physically yeah it's
huge you know they have the breathing
facial tension yesterday you're asking
me when I was sitting at the kit and not
the jaw yeah in the mouth and and we
were chatting about that last night it's
like well is it is it just from the
standpoint of teaching there's so many
different skills that can be enhanced
oddly enough by paying attention to sort
of mouth jaw tongue relaxation and we
were chatting last night and then is it
best to and tell someone to relax the
jaw or is that too hard and in fact if
you ask someone to relax the tongue do
you get that entire structure to relax
more easily
and all of which transcends music
specifically sure and this is a
conversation I've had a lot with someone
who's been on the podcast do Kelly
Starrett who always talks about
breathing in positions like if you can't
breathe in the position you do not own
the position that's why I was so excited
about doing this with you because I knew
there was going to be tons of carryover
from different disciplines and that's
what I really love and so you telling me
oh yeah if you if you relax your tongue
you'll relax your whole face and your
jaw that I was like of course that's
huge and that's the way I'm gonna
present it to people from now on yeah
because that's a better way to teach it
it's it's in you you now are having a
conversation last night romantic
candlelit that's true we did ice baths
which is also a great opportunity to
work on breathe breathe holy [ __ ] time
oh and we can have around two but the we
were chatting about in part we were
talking about a lot of things but what
what keeps me excited and my answer was
seeing the interconnectedness and and
the transferability of these types of
concepts because even if you bleed the
stone and work in one area on one
discipline and you get to a point where
perhaps you just feel fatigued and you
want to try something else but you're
not sure if you could ever recapture the
excitement you felt in the nascent
stages of that first dominant skill
mm-hmm for me it's been I've realized
that there are thousands of different
disciplines you could be exposed to and
take to like a fish to water because you
have knowingly or unknowingly developed
all of these meta skills that apply and
you gave me a few gifts yeah that I
alluded to fondling earlier and one of
them holding
here and I'd love for you to just tell
people what it is and why you gave it to
me sure so this is a book called the
inner game of tennis by Timothy Galway I
came out in 1974 and it's sort of one of
those books where people like oh yeah
that book it had a huge effect and
there's all sorts of spin-offs like they
enter they don't give up music actually
is a book and the amazing thing with
this book is I've read both of us have
read a lot about Zen Buddhism and the
thing about Zen Buddhism is by the very
nature of what it is it's very difficult
to pin down and point at directly and
define because it's so amorphous and
this is the first thing I ever read
where he nails it down in the context of
of tennis it's easier to do that way are
you a tennis player I'm not mm-hmm this
is important yeah so so the book talks
about essentially these two selves that
we have self one and self two so self
one is the analytical cruel self-talk
harsh critic who you know you hit the
ball in the net if we're gonna stick
with the tennis analogy and cellphones
like I you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] like
come on get it together and self two is
your subconscious automatic self that's
just hey I'm just trying to just trying
to make this happen here and the whole
idea is calming down the critical
analytical self one your self-talk right
and letting self to the automatic
subconscious takeover and if you let
that happen
everything will just happen on it
automatically so what's interesting is
what I do with so many people is very
technique oriented and this book can be
described as like an anti technique
because you're it's sort of the opposite
way of coming about it but what's
interesting about this is with the Zen
stuff they will lead you down a path and
then just leave you there a lot of times
and the the brilliant thing with this
book is it's very easy to understand
anyone can pick it up and learn you just
replaced
you're with any other thing any other
discipline the only thing in this book
is it takes you somewhere and then he's
like yeah so you know this is a this is
a plateau you have to overcome and this
is how you do it
and that happens multiple times this is
a little problem here a few approaches
to resolving this yeah as a you know for
instance if you're really getting in
your head we'll stick with the tennis
analogy in a match and you need a device
to overcome that solve one because like
I was saying earlier if you think about
physiologically what you're doing in
terms of movement you use a different
structure in your brain and you'll botch
it so if you're serving a tennis ball
you throw the ball up and go I throw the
ball up then I move my wrath you're
[ __ ]
yeah right you're gonna hit the net
every time so in order to not do that
he'll say focus on the laces of the ball
as it's coming at you or focus on the
whap of the sound when you get like a
good hit and just focus on those things
in and of themselves and that will take
you into that that space and we were
talking about this last night everyone
that talks about being in the zone or
being on fire or that kind of thing as a
state that you can willingly inhabit
it's it's not really a thing it's not
like true you can set the stage for it
by this type of thing but you can't
willingly enter into that or also
everybody would do that all the time
yeah and when I'm having these
out-of-body experiences when I'm playing
music which is what gets you to do it in
the first place sort of time slows down
and unfolds in front of you and you see
what you're gonna play and it neo back
bending example it's flying that's
exactly the same thing and that's that's
what gets you that's what got me hooked
that that yeah that matrix thing and you
can use that in any discipline yeah and
you can't as you said guarantee that you
can follow the boot-up sequence and
automatically enter flow at any given
point in time but you can increase the
curb solutely you can increase the odds
absolutely and
we were you're mentioning in the context
of say tennis or a tennis serve but last
night when we were tooling around on the
drum kit very similar right when you
were new and noting you're asking me to
note the difference in sound mm-hmm from
say switching from a so French grip if
I'm getting sort of thumb on top to a
German grip which is it's like alna more
dated flat hands matter him but using
the the wrists as a whip as a whip or I
guess it was a rimshot or yeah yeah
that's on the snare drum and asking me
to really notice like the feel and the
sound of it and what's amazing about
this is we're playing an electronic
we're not playing an acoustic kit so
even though you're hearing sounds
theoretically it shouldn't really sound
any different because it's not real you
know what I mean but this is that what's
even cooler about this being on
electronic it is like once we got you
relaxing and getting those those you
know those techniques happening and
trimming the fat it your vibe and your
feel was like totally different even in
that situation and the sound is or the
the cueing into that sound or feeling
much like anyone who's played tennis and
I've played very little tennis but knows
the gratification of that proper flack
really hit it in the sweet spot or
anyone who's boxed and found that sweet
spot on a heavy bag acts as an anchor
for the 27 biomechanical ingredients
that make it up but if you try to recall
the 27 separate ingredients sweetly when
you're pulling your arm back to hit the
ball you're [ __ ] you hit the nail on
the head man and that's and that is
exactly that's the kind of stuff that I
find so exciting is is are those
carryovers when you hit a homerun when
you smash a baseball it doesn't feel
like you did anything nothing how did I
that doesn't feel whereas if you hit it
like wonky you're like you know what I
mean like it feels terrible yeah and
it's this it's the same thing with drums
when you hit them right the intership
energy should be going out
not back in and it's the same with any
thing else any athletic movement and you
gave this book the internet' tennis too
and we're gonna definitely come back to
this topic but your therapist yeah who's
81 something like that yeah 80 something
and very wise woman yeah it's it now has
a prominent placement yeah on our shelf
yeah as a spot on her mantel as like one
of the five or six books she gives out
to people regularly you know I didn't
ask you this because I don't think you
mentioned the five or six other books
but do you know offhand any of us that
PML defacing love addiction is one of
them Pia melody Apia Mandy yeah I don't
know the other ones but we can make that
a bonus feature for the show notes
I'll look closer next time yeah let's
take a look at these other two sure
because I think they are also fun way to
dissect you a bit sure let's go with
this one next so this is a very small
book and I always get excited about
small paths would not think that is
every time I set out to write a 20-page
children's book it ends up being a
700-page like a bludgeoning tool because
this is title the medium is the message
subtitle an inventory of effects yeah
Marshall McLuhan yeah a little C
uppercase luh a n and Quentin furia yeah
this is the graphic designer
mm-hmm and then produced who notice that
by Jerome Agel I suppose no something
like that yeah yeah so who knows what
that's not something I typically
associated with books I'm not sure what
that means but tell me about this book
so Marshall McLuhan was a really
interesting and very popular social and
media theorist in the 50s and 60s so I
find it really fascinating that
that he's not a household name now being
that media is such a massive part of
everyone's life now especially people
who do their own thing like we have to
have Instagram and Twitter and all that
stuff like it's you don't rejoice right
so I I just I find I find societal
issues and and media and how we process
and consume media very interesting and
this dude was so ahead of everyone by
decades it's almost creepy just in in
terms of his predictive ability yeah and
and the interesting thing about him is
he would he would spout off all sorts of
inflammatory crazy things and people
would get you know furious about certain
things or pick things apart and he would
contradict himself all the time and make
these grand statements and that maybe
would have been something that would
have bothered me a years ago but now as
long as there are gems throughout and
these hits the nail on the head in
certain areas and I can take away things
that shift my perspective as a whole
that's all that matters to me so the
medium is the message
this is actually the medium is the
massage because they screwed up on the
rope that's so funny I didn't even know
well because they screwed up when they
were printing it originally and he
thought it was hilarious and he's like
just leave it that's fine also it was
supposed to be the medium is the message
but it's actually the medium is the
massage and he's like that's great if
you'd like loved puns and he's kind of a
quirky weird dude so the the whole idea
of that phrase is that the medium with
which information is submitted to you is
more important than the actual
information itself so an example I like
to use is something like auto-tune so
for people who don't know what auto-tune
is if you think of that cher song like
do you believe and laughs have to live
like whatever that was like 20 years ago
and it's it's so auto-tune is a software
that people use to correct someone's
vocal take so if someone's vocal take is
wonky they just sort of massage it a
little bit and use quite a bit
in hip-hop yes so so what the new thing
with that cher song was is they used a
different key signature to auto-tune it
so like so it way over corrected itself
and that's what got that weird teep now
t-pain sort of sound yeah and Drake and
now so like as something that was a
experiment now has currently changed the
way music is the software itself has now
changed the art form and to the point
where I'll have producer friends of mine
tracking someone doing vocals in their
20s and they're like hey why is my why
does my voice sound weird and they're
like that's what your voice sounds like
that's actually what it sounds like
corrected they expect it to sound like
auto-tuned
so the technology has now affected the
change the content but also changed the
perception mm-hmm of the raw materials
yeah and you could say the same thing
about there's something called beat
detective which is something that that
drummers the world over to hate so it's
the same sort of a thing for drummers so
like they can you can you can track
something record something in a studio
and then they will artificially adjust
everything to a coupe to a grid and if
someone's lazy about it they just snap
it to the grid and it's just I get this
very stiff and computer life because
that's that's what it's been turned into
back on drums yeah so so but people got
used to hearing me remove the soul music
yeah so I've done sessions were like
I'll go in and and I think do a pretty
good job and then I'll hear it back and
I'm like well how did you even have any
play on this because they just are lazy
it's more of that to speed them being
lazy and not going through and you know
but but people got used to hearing how
quote/unquote perfect that is and if
someone hears something that rushes or
drags or is a little bit not perfect ooh
this is weird and so a lot of things are
beat detected to the
where it's just totally artificial now
and then you've drained the blood yes
and then the pendulum will swing back
and you know that's why Adele was so
successful because it was real music and
Jack Johnson yeah yeah exactly if you
have the pendulum sometimes swinging the
abstraction is your interest in this
because I know it's not limited just to
this book and you know one I want to
bring up you have mentioned this to me
many times and in fact this is a a
documentary series that has come up
repeatedly on this podcast I'm
embarrassed to say that I still have not
seen it
Adam Curtis is BBC documentary series
the century of the self yeah and hyper
normalization yeah you know so you've
said it changed the way the that you saw
the world forever
and I'll just continue here so sure even
if you just check out the first these
are your words the first 20 minutes of
century of the south it will blow your
mind what why is maybe you could you
could segue into the century of the self
and hyper normalization tell me why this
is so interesting to you because this
seems to be fanatically something that
is of great interest to you yeah and we
were just talking about beat detective
and other things people might assume oh
it's because he's a musician and it's
how these things affect music but I
don't know if that's aI don't know if
that's true could you talk about how you
how did you find the century of the self
because it has come up surprisingly
frequently I'm sure gasps and why why do
why does it grab your attention my buddy
Chris is a musician's friend of mine and
he told me about it years ago I think it
came out in 2000 I think I'd have to
double-check that but it's the the
premise of century of the self is
mmm-hmm it starts with focusing on on
Edward Bernays so ever Bernays was
Sigmund Freud's nephew and he took all
of Sigmund Freud's theories on the
subconscious
and came to the conclusion that human
beings are either savage animals that
are going to rip each other apart or
they can be controlled and made docile
via consumerism
so the opiate for the masses
yeah it's literally that so so Edward
Bernays used some of these some of these
tactics that he pioneered in propaganda
for world war one and then after World
War one he was like oh well we can use
these in peacetime for capitalists
selling more detergent yes so the whole
notion of you buying a pair of shoes to
the express her inner self was
single-handedly formulated by him so we
think that's just always been around but
really before him if people were thirsty
they drank water if if people needed it
they would wear shirts for years and you
know as that dude who I am a big fan of
Slovak Slovenian philosopher yeah SLA
voj second name zi z EK amazing name
yeah
please continue amazing person we'll
come back to that yeah so what he talks
about he says you know if once you drink
coke instead of water that excess is
with us forever you can't go backwards
and so he did interesting things like
having a bunch of women smoke cigarettes
there was some sort of subconscious
phallic connotation with that but at the
time the women didn't smoke and he hired
like a bunch of attractive women to
smoke on like and like a parade or in
public or something to get it like quote
unquote sort of trending yeah
so the idea so based having the
celebrity wear the sneakers yeah exactly
so he created focus groups and he
created the idea of PR this is all him
so this guy single-handedly shaped
America as we know it and of course
America affects everything else in the
world up until recently anyway and
so especially the world we live in now
with Instagram and social media he's
maybe the most influential person I mean
in terms of society most people don't
wreck its it so it blows my mind he
should be a household name and mrs.
Edward Bernays yes and you know the
documentary grn ays yes wondering and
the dock and what's interesting is is
you would think he like you would think
he made himself famous via Sigmund Freud
but it was actually the other way around
he took all of his tactics and made
Sigmund Freud into Sigmund Freud huh
yeah it's crazy so that I didn't that's
I had no idea
yeah really wild so it's four one-hour
episodes and the first episode century
of the self yeah it's called happiness
machines that's the first episode and
Adam Curtis has a really interesting
style of making these documentaries I
saw him do a talk in Los Angeles when
hyper normalization came out in 2016 and
he said you know these aren't really
documentaries they're kind of just
things that I make and they're almost
like video essays or collages and
McLuhan talks a lot about about that
presenting things as sort of a star
pattern of images because language is
sometimes insufficient to convey the
ideas so it can be like a weird collage
like you're like what am I like I show
this documentary to feel like what is
this it's really strange and the music's
really weird and bizarre he talked about
sorry I'm talking about a hypernova
either one anything he's made anything
Adam Curtis has made us is the same
style and so it's for one-hour episodes
and it goes all the way up until the
Clinton administration because this idea
this ever Bernays stuff weaves its way
into politics and all sorts and it goes
into other things too so that completely
changed the way I think about everything
I think about it every day in what will
be an example is it just that you're
aware of the way your subconscious is
being manipulated is it
you view other individual and collective
behavior differently because you
question the free will ingredient it how
does it on a day-to-day basis impact how
you think about things or view reality
it's all it's all of that and and if
you're just let's for just talking about
consumerism if I want to buy something
whatever it is like a drink or a snare
drum which I buy a lot of or some art
which I also buy a lot of why I think
why do I want this yeah
what what's driving this and a lot of
times the answer is different than than
what you think it may be yeah or what
you want it to be yeah well a lot of
times you're feeling that if you're
feeling the void right so that's
something that that's a whole other
other topic existential angst but but
that's why a lot of people are you know
are buying things is to you know make
themselves feel better but you know I
heard this quote not too long ago it's
actually in a collection of course I
love it's just a collection of quotes
I'm such a like a promiscuous quote
reader sure but there is one and I don't
know the attribution someone out there
on the internet can certainly indicate
who the proper attribution is and I'll
actually I'll put it in the show notes
as well I'll write down this note
mankind existential animal quote
question mark and the quote is along the
lines of man is the only animal for
which his own existence is a problem to
be solved and I love that yeah I love
that that's it right there it's like my
dog Molly does not seem preoccupied
having a good time yeah
even you mentioned art work no and we're
gonna come back to some of the music and
we're also gonna jump into some of the
the rapid-fire questions
mm-hmm then I'd love to ask which I
haven't
I mean we've known each other for quite
a while but sure I don't think I've ever
asked certainly 90% of those great we're
going to be coming up on but the artwork
I follow you on Instagram
and I love your drumming don't take this
the wrong way I find the art work that
you discover to be fascinating Thanks
and strange you're welcome
so use your account also as a way of
discovering different types of graphic
design and art mm-hmm
have you always been interested in
visual art or and if not how did that
become what seems like an important part
of your life I don't know if it is yeah
it's a very important project it become
important why is it important I used to
make artis to draw a lot and do
watercolors when I was a kid and then
when I started playing drums like really
young like five six seven and then I
when I started playing drums I didn't do
anything else like it took my full
mental capacity so that sort of fell by
the wayside and then I hit a certain
point in my career where you know if you
just have those blinders on and you're
myopic about something because you're
very very focused and driven you end up
burning out of it eventually so and
touring isn't incredibly stressful so I
hit a wall a few years ago and how do
you know 34 okay so like 31 32 something
like that yeah
and I turned to art as a sort of oblique
form of inspiration I don't want to
hijack yeah the flow here when you say
hit a wall is that physical fatigue what
do you mean by mental fatigue mostly
because you get we were started talking
about this last night you get to a
certain point where you check all the
boxes of things that you've wanted to do
and I got to a certain point I was like
I've done everything that I wanted to do
career-wise right know what do I know
what do I do
Yeah right and also I was talking to
Jimmy Chamberlin about this I've been
he's a good friend of mine and I've been
helping him out a little bit who is that
he plays drums for the Smashing Pumpkins
and we were having breakfast
a few months ago and we were talking
about the same type of thing and he was
he was saying yeah people are like man
this is great your pants doing so well
or or your your your doing all these
tours and you're like isn't that amazing
and and I was saying yeah it's it's it's
not amazing I always knew I was gonna do
this this isn't this is a surprise for
me I always knew this was gonna happen
so in a way it's hard to get to the top
of Mount Everest and be like I did it
because you're like well duh of course I
did it now how much of that when you say
I knew it was going to happen how much
of that and there's certainly could be
an option C D and E but how much of that
is I knew it was gonna happen because I
knew I was really good versus I'm just
doing my [ __ ] job like as a
professional drummer like I am putting
in the work and therefore like it is my
job to ultimately do X Y & Z and I did X
Y & Z so why would I pat myself on the
back for yeah my job yeah sort of but
work something else well it's just like
I'm I have a lot of the ladder like I
just don't know what that quite a bit
I'm gonna work harder than you are you
know I'm gonna be the first end and the
last out and if if this guy can make it
work I can certainly make it work so
it's really that sort of a thing like
I'm gonna I always say this to people
I'm working with I'm saying look you can
have a good amount of innate ability at
whatever you're doing but the person who
puts the work and is always going to
surpass you and if you have a little bit
of an eighth ability like I think I do
and you work harder than anyone else
obviously there's a certain amount of
luck involved in anything which you
can't do anything about but there was no
other option yeah and with the thing I
was talking about with Jimmy is he was
like that this becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy down til you're down to the
molecular atomic level if you if you're
operating from that state things will
unfold in that manner because you're
you're working in that not like the
secret kind of [ __ ]
like not that crap but like Ivany
recommended this book to me and I and I
have so many books I have to read uh is
it like I'm becoming yourself it's super
popular right now after looking at
wonder who wrote it I have I have it in
my is it Krista Tippett no she's great
though she is yeah I'm reading this
Ellen Ellen Langer book mindfulness
which you're gonna super dig I've
watched you carrying it around yeah it's
so good and she what Ellen Langer was on
her podcast that was how I found out
about her all right so we will follow up
Jimmy recommended a book yeah they just
say beyond becoming something another
yeah after what's the gist of the book
did you recommend it basically goes way
into that in terms of a scientific
vantage point like how all of that stuff
works it's very besides you say that
stuff you mean when you place yourself
on a certain direction and make
thousands of micro decisions that are
subconsciously aligned with that
direction yes how things how does that
word fall scientifically mm-hmm instead
of some voodoo weird I want a new car so
I'm gonna put that into the end of the
universe and then it'll just happen you
know it makes me think again I'll be
gonna play it on the caffeine but I just
like jumping around and interjecting
because to hyperactive we were talking
about Maria Bamford yeah no [ __ ]
amazing comedian yeah yeah and at one
point she was doing this this bit on
having read the secret and so she said
that you know I went home and I created
a vision board and on my vision board I
had all the things that I wanted and my
sister came over and her sister
apparently is some very successful
lawyer or something and their sister
comes over very type A it's just like
what is this looks like that's my vision
board she's like you have a microwave on
your vision board she's like a [ __ ]
microwave that's ridiculous
I'll buy you a [ __ ] microwave and
then Maria's like BAM manifest about
trying to make that no no but I haven't
read it yet so I'm kind of talking out
of my ass here but he was saying it's
it's a kind of won't think it would help
you or why did he prescribe that because
we were talking about it anyway and he
was like oh if you read this book and
sort of
it's all about so I haven't it's in the
queue I haven't gotten to it yet what
did he share with you or what were his
thoughts on this position that you find
yourself in words like alright I've I
seem to have some degree of innate
ability for this particular field I was
drawn to it I'm Lyde myself very
diligently over at this point I guess
decades yeah yeah and I've done what I
want to do now what well and you said
something I don't know if you want to
debut it here or not I said oh my god
you should put that in a social media
just to further outsource your self
self-esteem sure which i think is like
social media in a nutshell but you said
you want to try take a stab at it I said
I said anyone who says do what you love
for a living and you'll never work a day
in your life hasn't done what they want
to do for a little bit yeah you do
anything day in day out yeah for decades
yeah there's a point you're like okay
even to the point where I'm doing these
tours where I'm super stressed out and
like you know you're walking in on the
stage and an arena for 15,000 people
Staples Center whatever and you're like
uh-huh you know after a week once I have
the show down I'm like yeah how whatever
Megan the donuts you know especially if
it's a pop thing because it's literally
the same thing every right every you
know if it's something more improvised
that's a little bit more exciting but
there's something that happens that I
have to help people out with who are on
tours for a year and a half or two years
and it's a pop context [ __ ] I didn't
realize tours were that long oh yeah
dude I'll be cycle totally so you're
playing the exact same thing note for
note say it's like being on book tour
until your next book comes out yep
basically well and then you'll take a
lot you'll do some recording you'll take
a break do a new record yeah but it's
intense and you're out with the same
people the same text yeah you're away
from your family it's pretty rough yeah
and so something that happens to people
is they're playing the same thing over
and over and over again I mean literally
this is no four-note because if you're
playing a pop like when I was doing
Miley that's a massive production so
eight busses twelve semis
the stage production isn't he's insane
I'm going up up and down above and below
the stage there's a huge video wall
she's riding a giant hot dog like 20
feet above the air in the arena there's
a lot of things that go on there so you
can't do anything different because
you'll be because the dancer a little
bit like what what just happened all
right so you have people playing the
exact same thing note for note for a
year and a half two years and they start
to lose their mind because it's so
monotonous and rehab is like the polar
bear doing like the lap in the one it's
exactly the same thing so what
interesting what starts happening is
your brain starts creating weird
Quagmire's for you to for you to fall
into because it's bored it exists so
like for instance you'll get to a
certain part and you'll be like why
can't I play that it's not hard to play
like there was a guys working with who
has played with like Janet Jackson for a
year you know a lot of people he's a
fantastic drummer and he had like some
issues with his with his foot and he
went to see someone in Atlanta like a
neural neurologist and she had some
helmet that he put on too because I we
were looking at like the technique the
physical issues and I guess there were
some parts of his brain that were like
turned off like to control the foot it's
crazy I don't know how that technology
works but your brain will will [ __ ] with
you yeah so though there was times at
the mars volta or with Miley or whatever
white where I would be like oh here
comes this part yes I got you're already
dead in the water yeah or like when I
was doing ma t3 there was one section
where like I would I would hear the beat
in the wrong place like weird he's like
an auditory hallucination yeah Wow yeah
and and like it was it was very very is
a very simple section and I remember it
sound check me like going whoa what's
going on here this is like it and your
brain is like I need something to do
yeah it's crazy
so I forgot why I got on that talking
about you're talking about Jimmy and oh
yeah
climbing Everest and what what his
thoughts were on what to do well his
Scituate we were just we were talking
about this order last night it said you
know in certain situations there aren't
a lot of people you can talk to
yeah not certain things right so we were
just kind of going back and forth at
that type of thing and the thing with
him is he is in a band that was that's
he's still huge and the thing with being
in abyss is the thing that's
uncontrollable in the music industry or
you know there's tons of parables here
but I can work really really hard and it
doesn't matter if my band makes it or
not in a way that if you really hit the
lottery that's totally outside of your
control so that they put in all the hard
work but that band had hit the lottery
yeah and that is out of your out of your
control but again you can sort of set
the stage for it so where he's coming
from because he's in a band that is huge
is totally different from someone like
me who's a mercenary Yeah right
so it's Blackwater sniper so it's it's
it's a it's a totally different thing
yeah but he's very very intelligent and
great player a really great guy too
he's amazing you guys would get along
really well yeah I'd love to meet him
yeah for sure how long has he been the
drummer with with he took a break for a
while and then he recently got back
together with them and they were just on
tour right now doing their new record
yeah there's so many tracks that just
fueled me through so many parts of
college so yeah the point zero butterfly
yeah I know bullet with butterfly
oh my god oh yeah that's amazing I think
we should maybe jump into some some
rapid fire but after end we will
incorporate this thank you for the index
finger points yeah we're not going to
miss this because you mentioned a word
earlier which is a very useful word
we're at oblique mm-hmm we're not
talking about the sides of your abs
although I suppose we are it's used in
that context see we're gonna come back
and talk about oblique strategies but
first since we've consumed I think
several black tea is several green teas
several topo chicas and are working our
way through a couple of cappuccinos and
more green tea we'll take a short bio
break and return for your listening
pleasure we'll be right in Rebecca
as promised oblique strategies this is a
black case that is holding what looks
like a deck of cards and this deck of
cards has all sorts of things written on
them the first two which I pulled out
yesterday which were highly highly
relevant to a number of corners I've
painted myself into recently were card
number one simple subtraction card
number two what mistakes did you make
last time what are these oblique
strategies so their cards that Brian Eno
and Peter Schmidt made together in 1975
and there who are those two people so
Brian Eno is a super famous musician
he's he's done a lot of different things
over the years but he was first famous
with the band Roxy Music and he when it
went on later to sort of pioneer ambient
music yes with the music for airport's
weight literally music forever that's
what the records called it's called
music for airport yeah clarify like I
feel like they would get along with
McLuhan a medium is the massage yes well
he he wanted to make something that sort
of neither had a beginning or an end and
you could tune in and out of and it
didn't really matter and so he's a very
interesting brilliant person and these
are strategies when you're making
anything I mean this is in the context
of making music but you can obviously
apply them to anything the device is to
knock you out of your present state of
mind like you said when you paint
yourself into a corner like yeah I gotta
get out of this or you just feel like
you've painted yourself into a corner
well that's a whole other thing right
yeah so there's a whole deck of cards
that are very simple minimalist
suggestions right so the ones that you
picked out you know we you already said
but if you pick if we pick out like just
a few random ones Heidi up do something
boring the most important thing is the
thing most easily forgotten ain't that
the truth mm-hm
overtly resists change discipline
self-indulgence yeah so these are
prompts yeah in a way for getting
unstuck or unfucked so you know I've had
I've had a set of these for years and I
thought you would be super into these
how do you use that how do you use these
cards and and I'll just buy a little bit
of time because I noticed there's a
there's a description card which I
hadn't noticed earlier these cards
evolve from separate observations of the
principles underlying what we were doing
what we were doing I'm imagining is is
very much musically related but
sometimes they were recognized in
retrospect ie
intellect catching up with intuition
sometimes they were identified as they
were happening sometimes they were
formulated they can be used as a pack a
set of possibilities being continuously
reviewed in the mind or by drawing a
single card from the shuffled pack when
a dilemma occurs in a working situation
in this case the card is trusted even if
its appropriateness is quite unclear
they're not final as new ideas will
scent themselves and others will become
self-evident yeah there you go how do
you use or how have you use these cards
I always think about them in terms of
how I'm supporting
music has you know on for the greater
good right so a lot of times in an
improvised context these are very very
applicable because with an instrument
such as drums or guitar or piano or bass
where you don't have to breathe to play
it yeah you run the risk of vomit chops
it means you you can just play as much
as you want if you're playing a wind
instrument you literally have to breathe
so that affects your phrasing so you can
pause hmm
you know drumming you don't have to do
that you can play a million miles an
hour forever right and and after two
minutes the listener wants to kill
themselves it's true there's yeah all
right there isn't sir VAP as much of a
there is a biological limiter but it's
not as obvious to the listener no yeah
with with with saxophone or something
you have to breathe every 15 or 20
seconds so you have to have space and
that cliche that cliche thing of it's
not about what you play it's about what
you don't play it's true it's cliché for
a reason it's really true and and that's
something that I try to focus on a lot
because it's if you have a lot of
facility yeah it's very easy to just you
know barf all over the place and
overwhelm everyone I'm not a musician as
I've stayed repeatedly but I remember
someone said to me music is the space
between the notes mm-hmm and I was like
mm-hmm
interesting and with drumming especially
because you're keeping time for everyone
it's it's a very meditative state a lot
of people will count in between the
notes and they'll be very precise about
it and I've always tried to be very zen
about it and just feel the void in
between the notes that you're playing
it's a totally do it's two totally
different ways of doing it and depending
on what you're doing at the moment one
could be better than the other but yeah
man so you would then give me give me an
example if you could yeah be
hypothetical yeah when would you pull
out this deck all right I really feel
like I need one of these cards so you
know I do a lot of the body mechanics
stuff with people and I
so have people who are just like hey
dude give me a bunch of cool crazy licks
to play in song Enders you know you know
that kind of a thing like I did that
with Stacey
my buddy Stacey Jones who's Miley's MD
and drummer and that weidy musical
director song and then here's an EpiPen
in the life yeah he was like hey dude I
just want to get some rad song Anders it
was like great we can totally do that
and so I showed him a bunch of licks we
had fun and this is the kind of
situation that's great for these because
people after you work on phrasing they
after about 20 minutes they've played
everything they know and then they're
like oh what do I do now so you could
just pick something out of the deck like
you just picked out give the game away
and how you interpret that you can go a
number of ways like slow down on your
shirt mm-hmm I mean anyone who picks
that up they're like what does that mean
like what does it mean to you like
therap eyes them yeah yeah exactly
so like for me the first the way I would
process that is like I'm just gonna a
lot of times when you're building up
solos you don't do that you want to lead
someone in and sort of set the stage
because if you start off on don't give
them the fleming young is the app time
exactly so this to me the way I would
interpret this is is I'm gonna come in
guns blazing and then try to work my way
out of that because that's the biggest
nono I'm gonna do that on purpose
right and then see what happens mm-hmm
someone could also someone's could also
say like if you're thinking about it in
a sports analogy you know you could just
be like I'm just gonna play the game and
see what happens just let it happen on
its own it's not about winning or losing
cool and dig it yeah yeah this is good
timing for me okay great so we've we've
talked a lot about playing in front of
huge crowds and the musicians you work
with and certainly this show tends to
feature people are very good at
something sure
I would like to talk about failures hmm
or disappointments and this is a
question I really enjoy asking which is
how is a failure or a parent failure set
you up for later success could be a
disappointment but or anything but do
you have any particular favorite
failures or failures that come to mind
that were in retrospect very valuable
I've gone out for auditions for for
plenty of bands and I haven't gotten
gigs yeah I mean that's just how it goes
and if you go in there and again you're
really prepared and you fully present
yourself accurately and they don't want
it's not the right fit what else what
else can you do you might think of that
God didn't get the gig like it's a
failure but what about if you it's the
same thing as dating right what if you
present a fake version of yourself and
then they like that then you have to
keep doing that and then you're like Who
am I yeah so there's plenty of
situations where I go in doing the Dave
smash thing like in that mars volta
video and they're like holy [ __ ] like
Jesus Christ it's like get her straight
away it's too much and they get freaked
out and that's just like well you know I
might not be that guy all the time but
that's definitely possible yeah a real
life situation which is what I always
try to talk about because that's the
most important thing so many people run
into problems when they just it fits
hyperbole yeah so when I was out with a
1975 maybe a couple years ago George the
the drummer I've been teaching him for
for a while and he broke his collarbone
on tour so is the same type of situation
car dude break his collarbone maybe it's
not higher I don't Emily I don't I don't
know I don't know but he was just like
dude I break my broke my collarbone so
you know good recovery kitchen
I was like who knows you know so so he
was like can you come out here and and
you know fill in so same type of
situation I have to learn all the music
last minute it's you know a big really
large venues arenas and I show up to
Toronto
meet everyone we have a line check on
stage which is you just make sure all
the connections are working we run
through a couple songs maybe the people
attempting to assemble my drum kit did
not do this another thing George I'm you
know I'm like five six on a good day
right George is at least a foot taller
than me if not more Wow yeah he's very
tall he's probably like six nine holy
yeah he's very tall so I had daddy
longlegs
yeah junkie yeah long legs long arms
long everything so I had to rearrange
his kit a lot of times you have to sit
down and just play it which can present
some promise but I had to rearrange
things it was like impossible and so
yeah outdoor stage in Toronto 10,000
people and you just have to go for it
now you were set you said you'd go
through a line check yes watch out for
the reservation yeah so line check is
like kick kick kick drum snare drum
guitar but you know like checking
everything's working right and then he
was the Oh Maddie the singers like can
we do this song through this song and we
just did like a couple songs and he was
like okay great and then it's just show
time all right yeah and and so you know
what everyone was like because that's
the type of situation where it's a band
and you have to come in and the very
difficult thing is you have to assume
someone else's character yeah and try to
make everyone feel comfortable enough to
where it's comfortable yeah right so you
know they were like yeah you know how do
they play it play the parts but like you
can have some fun and so I threw in
things here and there and they were like
laughing and into it and and it was
super fun and and so we did that run for
about a month and then I sat down with
Maddie at a sort of the singer and he
was like you know man we have to do
Glastonbury and some some BBC one stuff
and it's it's really important that this
band sounds like the 1975 and right now
it sounds like the 1975 with de village
mm-hmm as your personality is just huge
yeah and at the time I was like [ __ ] I
was so bummed because I really like
Maddie I really like Georgia all those
guys and I really like the music a lot
and I was just like [ __ ] man
and and then I was like wait this is
like the best compliment anyone could
ever give me
yeah cuz having an identity is the most
important thing when you're making art
and I was like you know what that's
[ __ ] awesome yeah and and so you know
that was they got they got them my buddy
Freddy who was doing it for the week
until I got there Freddy she'd is really
great drummer in the UK they got him to
do it again until George could come back
and and Fred he's great and he's a
really good buddy of mine he did a great
job and I was just at the time I was
like so bombed but what helped you
reframe it like when did when were you
able to reframe it and view it the way
took a while today took a few months did
you do it on your own did it come to
clarity through therapy what helped
maybe talk is a lot of people don't
recover from the they're not able to
reframe something that might have been
very difficult time it continues to be
something that was very difficult and
they just take it takes them out forever
you know it just becomes this pain this
like dull ache then they revisit every
time they have the memory button you've
been able to reframe it yeah I think
through enough experience and through
having enough success outside of that
situation yeah I can I can definitely
see that happening if it's like that's
your one shot and that's the only amount
of success you've ever had but I've done
a lot of other things and I did things
after that before and so it's like oh
that was just that one thing and it
wasn't like oh you you [ __ ] it up yeah
it was just like you're too distracting
what's the shittiest music gig you've
ever had
and it could be like oh man I thing it
could be anything it could be like an
halftime at like a rogue Olive Garden I
don't know man I don't know if I can
answer that without getting in trouble
or any have you ever have there any ever
been moments when you've doubted
yourself or doubted the music path where
you've just been like [ __ ] oh all the
time
what would any examples come to mind
they could be super early they could be
at any point well the industry has
changed so much in the past ten or
fifteen years just the way it's
structured as a business model alone it
makes you question things like is this
even a working model anymore
yeah and that changes on a daily basis
so just thinking about things monetarily
sometimes this even make sound like for
me like am I gonna go out on tour and be
away from home and make X amount of
money when I can just stay home and
sleep in my own bed and make X amount of
money teaching right yeah that kind of a
thing and then it's like well do I want
to teach you do I want to play music
what you know and then it's like the
grass is always greener so that all that
stuff's constantly swirling around in my
head yeah when you're auditioning for
gigs and you're like really that dude
got the gig are you kidding me and then
you're like if that's what people want
like that's garbage
like but yeah and everyone else is like
Oh gross and you know like I can't be
like that good dude such a cheeseball
like why would they you know and and
they were like well is that what people
want and then it's like if that's what
people want why am I doing this cuz no
one has good taste
yeah you get in that that whole thing so
just yeah totally the and I think what's
what's very important is doing a
multitude of things I a lot that's
really my bread and butter
but because of that I can be selective
and learn how to say no to themes
because of that so if someone calls me
for a few playing gigs yes yeah so if
someone calls me for a tour and I heard
a lot of bad things about the artist
like they're a pain in the ass I'll be
like now I'm good
yeah I don't have to do it I have a lot
of friends who tour and that's all they
do have to do and they're like god
you're so lucky you teach I have to go
out with this piece of [ __ ] right now
it's like and then it comes around to
doing what you love for a living you
know and then they're like ah like
what's the point if if you go out on the
road and you're bombing yeah so there's
something to be said about the weekend
warrior who goes to their suit-and-tie
cubical job and then they get out of
work and they're like yeah I'm gonna
play drums right now and they're stoked
yeah there's something to be said for
that yeah cuz it's still like a wholly
special thing and that's something that
I struggle with with art yeah because I
love arts so much and it's so important
to me and everyone's like when are you
going to start making stuff and it's
like but if I start making it right then
I'm part of it and then it's like
tainted yeah in a way well it makes me
think of some of my friends who are very
very successful travel writers mm-hmm
it's really hard for them to travel for
fun because they're constantly thinking
about what would the lead be oh how
would I describe this oh maybe I should
take some notes just in case they have a
very tough time experiencing travel
without thinking about how they would
craft the narrative well same thing for
me like if you go on tour a lot you
don't want to go travelling for fun
you're like I was just out for six weeks
I just want to be home yeah so like
everyone's like man you should take a
vacation and I'm just like I don't I
don't want to go anywhere I want a
staycation yeah you're talking about the
teaching which i think is really a point
I want to revisit because you do you do
multiple things you haven't um you have
many different interests yeah and it
strikes me that in a sense you've number
one diversified your identity in such a
way that you don't feel
psychologically compelled to always to
her secondly with the teaching and you
know with the online course getting out
of your own way which I think could be
like maybe it will be the title of this
podcast so interrelated as it relates to
that was a terrible sentence but you get
the idea
oblique strategies the inner game of
tennis I mean so many of these creative
pursuits professional pursuits of
personal pursuance are not about doing
something brand new that is this
gigantic skill you have to acquire over
15 years a lot of it is just removing
the blocks mm-hmm right but the point I
was gonna make is that you are not in a
position because you've developed these
different branches of your life where
you have to to feel or act out of
desperation and it makes me think for
instance this might seem like it's
totally out of left field but Arnold
Schwarzenegger mmm never really
auditioned and this is something not a
whole lot of people know about him it's
not a secret but he made millions of
dollars in real estate before he ever
had his break in film so he focused on
real estate in Santa Monica and other
areas and had also other types of
business he had a mail-order business he
had a brick laying business with Franco
Columbu so that he could be selective
about the roles he took that's
incredible and he was able to craft a
trajectory even one in didn't you
talking about the cheeseball taking the
gig yeah when he got started people are
like this is never gonna work
right you're a freak show right nobody
wants that right like people want Al
Pacino and taxi they do not want taxi
driver yeah actually after one of the
two thank you Robert De Niro
oh yeah close enough this is audio
Verret day phones I'll leave it in
well you get the idea yeah and he was he
was able to bide his time also so that
at some point he could he could put
himself in a position where he could be
exactly what people wanted and humor I
actually uh I'll give you a public
thanks also for you can see where my my
brain is connecting this for your
introduction to Bill burr sure immediate
who's also on this show who you teach
mmm-hmm
who for people who haven't seen it does
one of the most hilarious or else for
it's never bits of all time which I
won't spoil it is definitely not
suitable for work so don't play it at
full volume on YouTube about your job
then get pissed off at me on the
internet but the the diversification of
identity psychologically very very
important and then the the income
diversification for you allowing you to
then as an artist craft a more
deliberate path I think are really
really yeah absolutely really important
and if you're not being deliberate about
what you're creating then what the hell
are you doing you're just making garbage
right yeah absolutely
you mentioned George this is drug Daniel
right yep of the 1975 so yeah he has
said and I quote among other things I'll
read the whole thing but Dave saved my
arms and hands he made me see I could in
fact contrary to my belief developed
technique that would save me from
blisters and help solve ten denies for
many years of horrible horribly
inefficient technique we don't have to
talk about that we can but the next line
is what's interesting to me he taught
patience exclamation point an incredible
player really great teacher and
all-around lovely human what does that
mean or what does he mean by he taught
patience I think probably I'm very as
long as someone is putting the work in
I'm very patient with people because
seeing the light the light flash in
their eyes when something clicks is one
of the greatest feelings imaginable
and also probably for him
I think being patient with himself like
taking the time to really hone in on
certain things and not having to rush
through things and just family I'm gonna
put the work in and I'm gonna take the
time so all this stuff happens the way
it should happen and and you have to be
patient with that or else it's never
gonna manifest itself or with something
that's as physical as drumming mm-hmm if
if you rush it and your technique is not
bio mechanically suitable for a human
yeah human body then well that's what I
was that's what I was saying earlier is
is it's inherently an issue of the drum
set as an instrument in that the way the
drum set was formed initially around the
turn of the century was it was called a
trap kit because it was sort for
contraption so like you think of these
dudes around you know in late 1800 1900
s taking disparate concert percussion
instruments like a bass drum by itself
and a snare drum and then we had did
that make a pedal that used the bass
drum and the high hats were were
originally called low boys because they
were on the floor and you only played
them with your foot in playing so it's
evolved in this really bizarre strange
way so it's physically strange yeah but
also the bar is incredibly low in terms
of entry so it's very easy to play drums
in the beginning you sit down and go
doot da doot da doot da doot da hey oh I
couldn't play drums I can do this I can
play along to ac/dc and Michael Jackson
and like this is great and so no one
thinks about how anything functions
because they can already do it and then
they go on tour and then 10 years later
they're like oh my arms are destroyed or
my hip is just one of my back because
they're there doing everything and
efficiently or incorrectly and then also
they they get stuck as far as the
vocabulary goes because they can't
express themselves properly because
they're in their own way
yeah so it's a lot of it is inherently
part of the instrument
itself and I always use like violin is
an example like you have to sit there
for six months just getting your
intonation happening or saxophone you
have to get your embouchure together
your what embouchure um - sure yeah how
it's like basically throat control like
how you how you produce air pressure
yeah
and that takes a while you know if you
start learning Clara nadders that you
just squawking all over the place have
to develop that control and you can't
just sit down and just make a sound
you have to there's a certain amount of
gestation with the drums yeah you can
get the reward with that having to
develop immediately that body control
exact and that's the problem but that's
part of the the instrument you know what
I was going to say earlier we were
talking about the being able to to do
many different were many different hats
do many different things be deliberate
about what you're doing I had when I was
talking to a friend about this and he
was like yeah what you know if you if
your identity is is largely based on
what you do for a living
whatever it is what if you wake up one
day and you don't want to do that thing
and then you're like Who am I
yeah and that's a mindfuck very common
yeah it's super super common mm-hmm yeah
so I think having people who say like
try to retire and then they're like oh
wait I've spent 12 hours a day for the
last 30 years doing X and then you have
a whole other black hole where if you're
a very important person and you and you
get a lot of respect and then you retire
you're just some guy yeah and that's a
whole other thing to deal with yeah and
then what are you gonna do with your
with your life when you just wake up and
you gonna play golf all day you know
that's a whole other thing yeah huh what
would you put on a billboard if you
could put metaphorically write a message
few words a word anything on a billboard
to get it out to millions of people he's
holding this t-shirt look slow down yeah
yeah yeah slow down is because generally
speaking that as so many people need to
do that slow down take a deep breath
yeah just relax
you can also cover up or hide a lot of
your own mistakes and sloppiness from
yourself by doing things too quickly
absolutely that's very common in music
yeah very common music it's very common
in a lot of things
mm-hmm when I watch really good se
boxing instructors they're always like
slow down in the beginning certainly
sure look yeah anybody can flail their
arms around so that nobody can see what
you're doing exactly like you know I
want to see exactly what you're doing
really slowly in the beginning and
Menaul so brings to mind one of my
favorite expressions I've learned in the
last few years which was from a friend
of mine who's a former Navy SEAL and
it's not specific to him it's something
that you hear quite a lot but it is slow
is smooth and smooth is fast
hmm yeah just like all right I'm not
rush because if you try to like Russia
reload or rush whatever it might be and
you botch it
now you're really slow mm-hmm and you're
slower than then you would be even yeah
yeah yes what's that it's the same like
the weights can [ __ ] in the smaller
circles yeah to learn things in large
movements or whatever you want to think
about this in you know whatever paradigm
you want to think about sin and then as
you get more comfortable it gets smaller
and smaller and smaller yeah and then
you're just throw someone across the
room and for those people wondering says
Josh Waitzkin who it's a fantastic guy
good friend of mine who's thought of is
the basis for the book and the movie
searching for bobby fisher' really a
master in many many disciplines but
that's one of one of his concepts right
so I tell everyone I teach to get that
book yeah the art of learning is a
fantastic book he was the second ever
guest on this podcast yeah and a lot of
great concepts also for people
interested today did a television
episode with him where we looked at
Brazilian Jujitsu which is a black belt
in cool other things that was the first
time for that TV show that he got on in
front of a chessboard and I think I want
to say 15 years something like that his
wife said I cannot believe that he's
getting in front of chessboard I've
never maybe never seen him do it that
thing in the episode where he talks
about
like 50 chess games yeah the
simultaneous games
yeah and talking about feeling the flow
of energy in the room and then he felt
like a shift yeah he felt like he'd been
juggling 30 balls and one of them got
dropped because he was playing it was
something like thirty kids huh and one
of them cheated yes and he came back
around and he didn't know exactly what
had happened but he's like this doesn't
feel right and that sounds like spooky
[ __ ] that's a real thing
yeah I was that was so that episode was
so affirming and exciting for me yeah
because he said a lot of things where I
was like oh I'm doing this right yeah
I'm on the right path because there were
so many things that we did similarly
it's this it's the that the transfer is
so it's so clear huge which is part of
the fun it's a big part of the fun of
having this podcast for me as
interviewing people across disciplines
that at first glance you would expect to
have nothing to do with one another and
you just realized that people who are
playing their a game in any field mm-hmm
have more in common with one another
than they do with the B players in their
own field that's one of my favorite
things to do with BER is we sit down and
talk about comedy and drumming and the
massive amounts of overlap between the
two yeah like when we first started
working together he had basically like a
John Bonham Led Zeppelin almost like a
replica kicks like a huge Bonham fan and
everyone who plays drums is like a John
Bonham fan he's incredible and it varies
but he's a very specific sound so he got
this early seventies green Sparkle
Ludwig Kit giant 26 inch bass drum like
it's a hole it's a thing it's a very
specific thing and we're working
together and we're talking about
identity and what he wants to say and
who he wants to be and getting his
posture together and and I was like dude
you wouldn't walk out on stage and start
yelling like Sam Kinison that's his
thing you do your own thing you walk out
on a stage in front of whatever 12,000
people Madison Square Garden you're
doing your own thing
yeah like bring that to this
you sold the kit immediately got his own
thing he's figuring out what his own
thing is yeah it's it's it's and that's
so much fun for me to do you know and
he's one of the smartest dudes I I know
I'm he's brilliant he's very smart guy
yeah yeah you have then within any field
certainly you have certain philosophical
underpinnings or paradigms that people
choose as the foundation for a lot of
their decisions and career paths and so
on then you have the strategies and you
have the tactics and the the lower level
you go in some respects the more the
fields diverge mm-hmm but certainly at
the higher levels whether it's tennis
comedy drumming or otherwise there's so
many so many commonalities yep what is
an unusual habit or an absurd thing that
you love that I love you know I'll give
you an example yeah or just compulsion
so for instance Cheryl Strayed who wrote
the book wild and excellent author also
fantastic podcast host the example she
gave was she likes to reassemble
sandwiches so she gets a sandwich it
bothers her like all the tomatoes on one
side of the sandwich and the avocados on
the other she wants every bite to be as
uniform as possible
so should I can reassemble her sandwich
I like the number 555 because I finished
editing the final line and the final
pass of the 4-hour body in a samovar tea
shop at San Francisco ages ago and
looked up and it was 555 p.m. so that
became this kind of good-luck charm so I
take screenshots of that whenever pops
up so it could be anything it's funny I
think to be good at anything you need to
have a touch of OCD yeah absolutely you
have to be detail-oriented that I do
have those things but I can't think of
anything off the top of my head other
than like checking the stove 10 times
and only think that you know checking my
studio door four times make sure it's
locked I can't like think of anything
weirdly specific like that at the
and no problem I'm sure there there's
there are depths to slum they're then
returned to ya how often do you eat
Indian or Himalayan food with some type
of curry type consistence every day
pretty much I mean that's why I go to
the gym six days a week because I have
to work off all the all the clarified
butter alright I'll leave that that may
qualify when you feel actually I'm not
gonna ask that one oh yeah let me go
somewhere else
sure see one thing that's come up in our
conversations recently because I've I've
never worked with a therapist mm-hmm and
I listen to interviews you've done where
you've mentioned therapy and your
therapist and I've always had I think a
certain degree of resistance
particularly to talk therapy mm-hmm for
a lot of reasons I won't bore everybody
with and I'd like to talk about that
because it seems like you've benefitted
tremendously from it so why if you're
comfortable talking why did you end up
engaging a therapist and what have been
how did you have you choose your
therapist and what have been some of the
benefits that you've derived sure from
it so far yeah I initially because you
it sorry yeah I'll just really continue
to step all over your answers all good
you as well as a few other people when I
have mentioned that I've not worked with
the therapist they're just like what in
the [ __ ] are you serious Peschel ii you
really like okay maybe this is something
I should explore yeah absolutely this
has come up multiple times from multiple
people so yeah your story so I started
seeing a therapist around when I was 30
ish like that and it was mainly to
figure out sort like relationship issues
that kept happening
over and over and over again and I was
like there's clearly something here
that's a blind-spot to me and I don't
know what I'm doing I need to figure
this out that was this specific reason
why I started going and I found my
therapist through a really close friend
of mine who is a therapist and we
obviously can't work together because
she's a close friend of mine so she was
like you should see this person she's
incredible and seeing it working with a
therapist having having a good
relationship with someone where you can
really trust them and you care about
each other and and and it clicks that is
unbelievably important you know there
are so many bad drum teachers out there
and there are so many bad therapists out
there and it's it's can be extremely
damaging to someone so having a good
good therapist who you get along with
and connect with and who's very
confident like that's why I pick someone
who was I mean we hit it off and it was
obvious but she's 80 yeah and it's like
it's like these all these life coaches
running around who were like 25 it's
like the [ __ ] do you know anything so
having a therapist to where I can bring
up anything and she's like yep been
there right right that's huge yeah and
so it started off with the relationship
stuff and then it obviously shoots off
in all these other different directions
and even just having someone to go in
and dump on and just like brain vomit
who's only there to help you out help
you sort some things out if the world
would be a completely different place if
everyone had that had a safe outlet yeah
to just unload what are some of the
ingredients for success say in the
beginning would you say that it's it was
important to you to say meat every week
for a certain period of time given how
much you could potentially travel sure
like what were what were some of the
things that made it work what's the same
thing with with drumming I'm like hey
look if you're serious about this we got
to do this once a week because it's like
going to the gym you don't go two days a
week for four hours right you go once a
week for every day you go every day for
an hour or something yeah
it's is you grat you you have
consistency that's crucial and you're
able to make progress because it's a
it's a recurring dialogue here are you
having with someone and so I went once a
week for years and when things got
particularly messy I would sometimes go
twice a week and there were times when
she really saved save my life like
dealing with PTSD or you know you
literally feel like you're gonna die so
and now I go once a month mm-hmm and
sort of check in and what's funny we
were talking about this last night if at
times when I'm like everything's kind of
cool like I think I don't even really
need to go today those are the times
when you stumble into some massive
paradigm shift and it literally is it's
a paradigm shift you see the world in a
completely different way and a lot of
the times when that happens it's funny
I'll just be talking out loud like
thinking but verbalizing it and you sort
of get on a path and then you like boom
and something happens and you're just
like holy [ __ ] like where did that come
from
yeah it's almost like an out-of-body
experience so a lot of it is is is
trying to get outside of yourself and
which is extremely difficult and
thinking about well is this is this
aspect of my personality is this learned
from my parents or or someone some
someone else or is this part of me and a
lot of things that I didn't know I was
even doing are learned things that can
be unlearned you might take a lot of
work it takes a lot of work it's the
hardest thing I've ever done but I am a
completely different person like a very
specific example that's like something
small if I'm at the gym and someone
reacts their weights and properly it
drives me [ __ ] bananas that drives me
crazy like if they take the the 25 split
on the 30
oh my god drives me crazy and it's like
this could not be more black-and-white
like how'd it like how is that
acceptable yeah and then that [ __ ] up
the flow for everyone else so like so
you know and one day she was like well
you know they didn't see that you were
wearing your invisible police uniform
they just didn't see it I was like and I
start laughing and I'm like oh my god
you're totally right like a feeling this
need to police everyone and continue and
it's obviously a need for control yeah
right which is a learned thing yeah
and that's something that I constantly
have to check myself about you know and
and and if you'd and and that that'll
take you out yeah cuz there's so many so
many things like that on the dailies
yeah hundreds thousands yeah that'll and
they're everywhere why does this guy not
know how to use his chip reader Oscar
yeah or like why did you park like an
[ __ ] yeah it's mostly like people
being inconsiderate that drives me crazy
I have one friend I'm not sure he'd want
to be named explicitly so I won't
mention his name he's a very very
brilliant guy in his field and when he
goes through TSA and airport security it
drives him completely [ __ ] bananas
when people don't know how to go through
security and gonna leave their belt on
or well have like a huge container of
water after the person has asked them
four times if they have any liquids so
what he started to do
he's been also very recently seeing a
therapist and has figured out certain
coping mechanisms and so one of his
coping mechanisms which I think it is
really hilarious is he will he will say
something like he will he will become
the voice that he imagines they have
that is 30 feet away so he'll go
on the airplane last time I was here I
could bring my computer through the
metal detector and he'll do this and so
I remember asking him at one point I was
like oh that's really funny so that's
what you say to yourself he's like no
that's what I say out loud and he says I
say it loud enough so that everybody
around me can use and people start
laughing and like chill the [ __ ] out
there's a way to defuse it I think he
just did it initially because he thought
it was hilarious and uncomfortable to
say it out loud now he's become like a
stand-up comedian at the back of the
line and I now know at least a half a
dozen people have spent time with him
and out where he is but it's the little
things that are the big things and it's
and it's also like why would it's also
for like TSA employees driving me
bananas I travel a lot and a lot of them
are totally incompetent so but it's like
going to anything where you have to deal
with someone in that type of a job yeah
you go wait why would this person be
competent yeah a competent person
wouldn't have this job in the first
place so why am I expecting that to
begin with I'm setting myself up to get
angry yeah right yeah it's this it's the
small things we think about these big
existential dilemmas and questions but
it's in so many cases that stuff is
important or it can be important but
it's also like are you giving yourself
like a hundred Pat's on the back in your
day or are you giving yourself a hundred
paper cuts because you've got you have
ample opportunity for both and and you
and you know what we're talking about
might sound trivial but you stack all of
those things up and they'll take you out
oh yeah for sure
oh my god we will at some point maybe
tonight over some wine come back to more
unusual and absurd things you love
because I'm sure there is a treasure
trove yeah one or two last questions
you've mentioned a few books here that
you gifted to me which are very very
timely but are there any particular
books that you've given the most as
gifts to other people
the andre agassi open book is phenomenal
incredible book even if you don't care
about tennis at all it is an incredible
book i tweeted years ago it's like hey
does anyone know any good sports
psychology books like in it directly
related to tennis or golf because i was
really fascinated with those even i
don't really give a [ __ ] about sports
really but i was really fascinated
because this this psychological warfare
you have to navigate by yourself is the
same as when the red lights on in the
studio have to do these film scores
where you have to sight read everything
you've never seen it before they throw
up a book sight reading is you've never
played it you've never seen the music
before they throw up the sheet music and
you have to replay it perfectly the
first time because you have to do the
whole movie in a day she's right so it's
very very stressful so it's the same
it's the same eluting films like trolls
the book of love others Logan that
Wolverine me so yeah that st. Vincent
movie with Bill Murray a few years ago
that all the divergent insurgent like
same same same same but different right
in terms of the sports the tennis the
golf yeah like when you hit the ball in
the sand and you're like [ __ ] and you
can't and you have to go just leave it
be and you have to you can't let that
ruin the whole game yeah same sort of
thing when the red lights on in the
studio or in your own playing in front
of 30,000 people it's the same you screw
something up you can't feel like oh and
then let it screw up the whole show it's
the same exact thing and I thought that
was fascinating
it was the Agassi book recommended as a
result of that yeah so you put up yeah
yeah and yeah I was like oh my god it's
credible it's all right tremendous book
I give that to people all the time
tarting I give to people all the time
Josh Waitzkin yep
I give at the inner game of tennis
I give Zen in the art of archery to
people yeah all the time I feel like
that was the very first book that
spawned all of these n in the art of
film blanket yes yeah it's just so
popular now I need to look at my
bookcase there's so many horton hears a
who last but not least there's so many
you are one of the best read people I've
met in the last I would say five years
was just saying a lot yes I know I made
a lot of people who read very widely and
this has been so much fun we could go on
for many many more hours so maybe we'll
maple do that at some point but where
are some of the best places for people
to find you we talked about debut let's
calm mm-hmm Instagram Twitter at de
village there are other social profiles
I'm sure but it seems like maybe those
are the best the online course which is
is really stunningly shot and very well
done getting out of your own way that's
available at fabulous calm yeah any
other places where where people can find
you they'd like them to pay attention to
or any other recommendations or asks of
the audience people who are listening
well the easiest place to find these
Instagram just Dave illage or my website
you can contact me through my website
I'm not super active on Twitter or
Facebook anymore you know someone else
who a lot of books I recommend are
Douglas Coupland books he wrote
Generation X : c oup l am yeah he's also
he's also an equally amazing visual
artist which is incredibly rare i find a
ton of inspiration from from him he's
he's he's great so i recommend a lot of
his books generation axes is great like
social commentary from like the early
90s and he coined that term yeah
generates neck mmm-hmm
he's an interesting sort of social tech
theorist i think he I think he has a job
at Google now
very well could yeah they tend to gather
interesting eclectic folks yeah he's an
interesting dude so yeah those are that
those are the two best places to contact
me my website or Instagram and if any
you know if anyone hears this and
there's sort of kindred spirits in terms
of what motivates us or in terms of any
sort of creative endeavor reach out and
say hey lob out a note or a hand wave
through the ether yeah that is the
interwebs hmm Dave so awesome to finally
get you on yes and do that many many
adventures ahead I'm excited for you I'm
hoping to pop in to the master class
tomorrow which I would be completely
unqualified for nonetheless has a
fly-on-the-wall awesome I really look
forward to that and you know before I
was before I forget daughters of Mara
yes that is Mara I've never thought to
ask this but is that a reference to the
Hindu god no I can't I think it's boot I
think it's Buddhist yes Buddha yeah Mara
who's sort of the equivalent of the
devil the devil yeah so we had three
daughters that would sort of tempt
people sort of like this the the snake
in the garden of you and equivalent
daughters of Mara yeah that was a band I
was in in 2005 6 7 that was on virgin
Capitol Records and did a record and
then EMI got bought out by Terra Firma
and and that was that
I am destroyer appropriate yeah very
little did we know Dave smash everybody
listening as always you can find links
to all the things we talked about
including say the crazy mars volta video
and we will also look up a few other
things like the the books that in
addition to the PM LED book the other
books perhaps some of the books that
your therapist has I'm sure her mantle
and the mankind existential animal quote
question mark etc will all be in the
show notes you can also find links
certainly to getting out of your own way
and everything related to dave at tim
dot blog forward slash podcast and until
next time thank you for listening hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me and would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm all
the spell out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
audible audible provides an unbeatable
selection of audio books including
bestsellers how-to mysteries thrillers
memoirs and more I've used audible for
many years and I have a few audio books
to recommend right off the bat number
one ready player one by Ernest Cline so
listen to the book that caught the
attention of Spielberg enough to get
made into a major film the writing is
fantastic Tao Seneca by Seneca the
younger this is a collection of letters
my favorite compilation of letters up
all time that I've recommended the most
of all the books that I've read and the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman this is
the fiction book that I used to convert
nonfiction purists into fiction lovers
I like the version that Neil reads
himself but that's just me is a hypnotic
voice I also recently enjoyed nonviolent
communication by Marshall Rosenberg
which was recommended to me by
best-selling author in Neil Strauss make
sure to get the audiobook version
and you will recognize it by the peace
sign on the cover and as an audible
subscriber you can choose three titles
every month one audiobook and two
audible originals you can't hear
anywhere else and there's some really
really cool stuff among the unrolled
originals
you can listen on any advice anytime
anywhere at home at the gym while you're
cooking on your commute or wherever I
often listen to audiobooks when I'm
walking my pooch or on the way to gym so
on and so forth you'll also enjoy easy
audio book exchanges in other words if
you don't like what you buy you know
like buyer's remorse you can swap it
rollover credits so if you don't use
credits and give it a month they roll
over into the next and an audiobook
library you keep forever even if you
cancel this last part is important
unlike say a streaming or rental service
with audible you own your books even if
you cancel your membership and right now
for a limited time you can get three
months of audible for just 695 a month
that's six dollars and ninety-five a
month and that is also more than half
off the regular price so give yourself
the gift of listening and while you're
at it think about giving the gift of
audible to someone on your list for more
go to audible.com forward slash tim t IM
that is audible com forward slash Tim or
text Tim T I am - 500 500 this episode
is brought to you by fresh books fresh
books has become the go-to cloud
accounting software for literally
millions of small business owners who
found a faster more efficient and much
less stressful way to deal with their
numbers and ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at it is used
by many of the fastest growing startups
I've invested in or advised and it's
equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid to track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 seconds you can
set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about two
clicks which on average will get you
paid twice as fast
their new proposals feature means you
can include a project summary and
timeline as part of your estimate there
are many many other things
tracking your time the quick proposals
that I mentioned formatting free
super-easy late payment reminders you
don't have to chase people automatic
expenses sharing files and messages with
your clients award-winning customer
service they are extremely responsive
the interface is super intuitive and
there's almost no learning curve so in
short it's easy it saves you time and
right now fresh books is offering an
unrestricted 30-day free trial for all
of my listeners to claim yours check it
out go to FreshBooks dot-com forward
slash Tim and enter Tim Ferriss in the
how did you hear about a section and
that is funky spell t IM fe r RI SS so
again go to fresh books calm ford slash
tim and enter tim ferriss and how did
you hear about us session check it out
you
you